hello welcome everybody happy easter
sunday
john perry here today with sunday
morning science
i was going to have my brother on
today my twin brother he
we were planning to do it because
people always my friends and family like
to
send me text messages from time to time
asking me questions about evolution and
mike was having some questions about
uh you know if microbes can evolve so
quickly because their generations are so
short
why is it that they cannot overtake you
know humans
and other multi-celled organisms that
reproduce slowly
why is it that they don't just get an
advantage and cause the extinction of
these
uh larger organisms so that's what we
were going to talk about today but then
we realized
oh it's easter and his kids are going to
be hassling him in the morning if he
tries to do a show
because you know it's easter and they
want to go find
eggs and candy as is tradition
in his house so that didn't work out
but he'll probably come on next week to
talk about that
and that'll be a fun conversation so
today i just wanted to do
um you know something fun about
the evolution of ears i mean ears come
on it's
it's it's easter so um
let's see here
ah welcome everybody i'm seeing quite a
few people in the chat now
in brazil it's 12 o'clock i'm told
you're just an hour off for me if that's
if that's 12 noon
yeah that would make sense are you in uh
sao paulo
uh felice pascua
let's see so you know it's easter
so might as well talk about the
evolution of ears right
here's my my easter rabbit my jackrabbit
here
and there's all sorts of cool things we
can talk about with
the evolution of ears but
i have been i was thinking about this
this week
because i saw a video which i'll be
talking about
here in a little bit about how the bones
inside the inner ear work
and this just got me thinking uh well
let me just show you so sound in general
is it's super interesting how it works
and
maybe this is super elementary for
people but
uh i actually didn't really get into how
sound works
until probably i don't know
three years ago or so when i started
really trying to understand the physics
of it
but you know sound i think it's general
knowledge that sound is just
compressed air so here we have this
little diagram
where the the dots here represent air
molecules now air molecules don't
actually just sit there
like this and bounce off of each other
they're actually bouncing off of each
other and every which way
constantly colliding with one another
but a sound wave
is when you have something that you know
pushes them
and they create this wave pattern and
when that wave pattern hits your ear
you interpret that your brain interprets
that as sound
so there's just a certain frequency
where it works i mean if if there's too
much
air moving all at once you would
interpret that as wind
right or if there's too much it can be
uh
it's you know non-audible there's a very
specific frequency that you can actually
detect with your ears but that's
essentially what sound is it's air
compressing and decompressing in these
little waves
that then hits the eardrum and ends up
going into the
cochlea so that's the cochlea there
that's the part of your ear
that actually does the hearing and
i know for most people this is kind of
review but
the cochlea is where the actual hearing
takes place
and if you look inside the cochlea there
are all these little what we call hair
cells uh those are not individual cells
there's actually one cell and those
hairs stick out of the top
and they're not really hairs they're
they're
uh i guess microtubules coming out of
the
cell membrane that the cell membranes
actually surrounding them
so they're little little little
protrusions
in the outside of the cell and when
the sound passes over them they wiggle
and that wiggling causes an accent
action potential
which causes a uh a nerve
reaction and the signal sent to your
brain
so that's it's amazing how this works i
mean everything
all of our sensory organs you know your
the nerves in your hand
the the nerves in your retina the nerves
in your ear
all they're doing is they're taking
they're transforming physical events you
know in the case of your eyeball
it's the reaction with a photon in the
case of your ear it's the the bending of
these little hairs you're taking
physical events
from the outside world and converting
that into
impulses that your brain can then
try and make sense of and that is how
that's basically how everything works
it's crazy
that things work this way um and feel
free to
uh put down any questions in the
comments there and when you do
do at stated casually and make sure you
put the space between stated and
casually
and that will highlight it so i can see
it i don't have anyone helping me
with the comments today so it's going to
be a little bit uh harder for me to see
people's questions so if you can do that
that'll be helpful
so yeah so that's basically how the ear
works and
your eardrum however is
fairly far away from the cochlea from
the actual part of your ear that does
the hearing
so the eardrum is separated by the
cochlea by these three little bones
here and i just i guess i never thought
about
how weird this is like why is that why
are they separated
why isn't the eardrum just like on the
side of the cochlea
itself and it turns out that the reason
for this is that the cochlea is filled
with liquid
and if you know anything about well
if you've ever been swimming you know
that if you're under the water
and someone's talking to you from above
the water it's extremely muffled
and this is the reason these little
bones exist
these bones help magnify the sounds that
the
eardrum hears and then
right here they actually are
pounded into the cochlea there's a
little there's a little window there
a little another little membrane there
where this this last bone
hits the cochlea and it transfers that
sound
those sound vibrations into the liquid
of the cochlea and the reason that
you need all this this entire lever
system is
because liquid is harder to move it's
harder to vibrate than air is
so this magnifies the sounds that you're
hearing
makes it so they're not muffled when
you're trying to listen to someone talk
because we live in the air and for some
silly reason
our hair cells are in liquid
and this this
when i started thinking about this was
kind of a mystery to me because i know
having talked to my entomology friends
that insects here with their antenna
they don't
this this design if you will is
unnecessary the the fact that you have
your sensory organs
covered in water essentially i mean it's
it's not just water there's other
molecules in there and inside the
cochlea but
why on earth is it that everything's
just
coated in water when that's completely
unnecessary insects don't do that
they're
they actually sense vibrations in the
air directly
with uh some some do it with their
antenna some do it with
little tiny hairs sticking out of their
body so why can't we just do that why
can't we just
have a an ear that works in the air that
would be so much simpler than having to
have this entire lever system here
now there's a there's a wonderful video
that got me thinking about this actually
this is the thing that stimulated my
thoughts on this this week
by steve mold if you are not watching
his videos
you really should he's he
i would say he focuses mostly on physics
but his stuff man it's so good he uh
he he talks a lot about the he he builds
these little models
and films himself playing with him here
he's he's playing with a uh
a uh a wave machine that he'd made
to to show you why uh you need to have a
lever
in between the eardrum and the ear
the the cochlea and this video is just
absolutely amazing so
what he does in that videos he explains
what the lever does why that lever is so
important
but he didn't address this question of
you know why on earth
are our auditory sensors stuck
inside of liquid in the first place why
on earth did that happen
so that's what got me thinking about
this why
do we need to do this and the answer of
course
well here's here's here's a diagram
showing how insect
um hearing works they actually do it in
their antenna
but the answer to why our
ears are stuck in a tube filled with
water
is fish fish are the reason
our ears evolved from fish ears and
if you're not super familiar with fish
anatomy that might sound weird
like fish have ears i've never seen a
fish's ear before
but they do have ears they have little
ears and
internal ears inside their heads here's
a drawing of one here's the actual photo
of one down here
and inside those ears we also have
excuse me we also have the hair cells
and you can see the cells here with the
hair sticking off the top
i believe my next slide has ah yes
so this is actually from a fish the
what's colored
blue here this is an electron microscope
image
the the blue things colored hair are the
hair uh
the ear the hearing uh
hairs of a fish so there
our ears came from theirs and you can
see
their inner ear is actually very similar
to ours this is from a sea bass i
believe
this one here the one pictured here and
it's very similar i mean the
the vestibular organ up here which helps
you get
your balance that's already well
developed in fish
they can actually keep their balance
underwater so
all this stuff evolved in fish and it
was so
well perfected at the time that our
ancestors our ancient ancestors
started coming out of the water that all
of us are stuck with the fish design
all tetrapods so all four-legged animals
with backbones
plus snakes and a couple others that
have lost their limbs since then
but all of us vertebrates are stuck
with fish ears and so for those of us
who live on land
that means that our hearing is
not good until we evolve
some way to transfer that the sound from
the air
to the inner ear so you might have
you might have heard that there's a lot
of reptiles that have horrible hearing
and it's because they haven't really
developed a good uh solution to this
problem
mammals did they found a very unique
solution with the three bone system
birds found a different one and lots of
different reptiles have found different
solutions
to to transfer the sound from air into
this
liquid environment but that liquid
environment comes from fish because fish
and actually any animal that's living in
the water doesn't need that special
system
if if you live in the water and actually
whales this system is actually
broken in whales it doesn't doesn't do
the same thing at all
in wales and whale hearing is not
super well understood but they they no
longer use this three bone system the
bones are still there
but they're not being used in the same
way and you just don't need that if
you're under water
you don't need this magnification you
can hear other things underwater just
fine
without it because the the water is the
same density
as the liquid at roughly the same deck
with density as the liquid inside the
cochlea
and so you do not need this
magnification mechanism at all this
lever to magnify
the sound but
yeah that that is the answer to this
question
of why our ears need all this fancy
equipment
in order for us to hear on land it's
because they evolved from fish ears
and things get even stranger than this
um if i go forward here
you've probably noticed on the side of a
trout or
any fish really there is this line it's
called the lateral line
and you may have heard that the purpose
of that organ
is to detect water pressure and it's
actually more than that they detect
not only can they detect water pressure
so they can they can roughly figure out
how deep they are
they could also detect really tiny
vibrations
and water pressure around them which
helps them in when they're
when they're swimming in a school they
can actually feel without seeing they
can feel their neighbor's movements
and they're extremely sensitive
predators will use this sensory organ to
follow the the pathway of their their
prey as they're swimming through water
they leave these little wakes
and those can be sensed with the lateral
line so they can
can help them hunt their prey it's an
extremely useful organ and it turns out
that it is filled with hearing cells
these same hair cells that we saw
earlier
what we call hair cells that are used
for hearing in the inner ear
are found in the lateral line and it's
actually not clear
which organ evolved first the lateral
line
and the inner ear is found on the most
primitive of fish
the um the jaws jawless fish
and so we're not sure which one evolved
first and of course
neither of these structures leave a very
good fossil record
but it's just really interesting the
same the same system exists
it's basically like a fish has a giant
ear stretching all the way back to its
tail
which is really cool so
anyway i came across this fact this week
and i just had to i had to talk about it
it's so cool
the reason that our ears are so weird
and require all this fancy machinery
is because they evolved from fish and
we've had to tinker with them
since to make them work on land
so i've got a question here
from keith
langford are there examples of dry ears
uh yes i maybe maybe you weren't here
when i was talking about that earlier
but insects actually have dry ears
they they
they some use their antenna some have
patches of
their exoskeleton with extremely fine
hairs that stick out and we've found
that
through different experiments that if we
stick electrodes to the to the nerves
that come out of those on the back side
we can actually stimulate them with
sound and we actually we see that they
are actually
sound receptors so there's actually a
bunch of different ways that insects
have evolved hearing
uh that that all use a dry system they
don't they don't have this
problem of the sensor being covered in
liquid
and you know why is it that insects were
able to do that while we were stuck with
uh wet ears it's probably just because
our ears were so developed before our
ancestors
came on to land i mean they're extremely
well developed in fish
the other possibility might just be that
insects have been on land for so
stinking long that
because their ancestors were aquatic as
well but they're
they've been on land for so long that so
much longer than us
so so much longer than tetrapods have
that they've
they've been able to develop this this
uh
adaptation where they actually have dry
ears so yeah
it would be more efficient but it's
really difficult for evolution to kind
of
when something's working pretty well
because even
even a muffled ear because you're out on
land
just like your ears work okay in the
water when you're trying to hear someone
above the water you can't hear very well
it's it's muffled but it still does work
and
in order for a new hearing system to
evolve
it really has to be better than the one
you currently have
and for a totally new system to evolve
in a tetrapod that already has sort of
muffled hearing
well it's a lot easier for that muffled
hearing for some sort of adaptation to
start
that makes that muffled hearing better
on land than
some adaptation to start that that's
rebuilding
an auditory system from scratch and so
that's why
that's why evolution gets stuck with
these really bad designs that it has to
tinker with
to make work uh you know
we now have a system that can fail in
many different ways
instead of a system that could only fail
in the in the cochlea right
we now have a system that can fail at
the eardrum it can fail at the
at the lever system between the ear
eardrum and the cochlea
and it can fill in in the cochlea so
we're now vulnerable to all sorts of
uh you know horrible things happening to
us
that uh we wouldn't be if we were you
know like insects just evolved
a an auditory system from scratch but
the selection pressure
was set up in a way when we first came
out onto land that that just really
wasn't
uh an option for us so it's it's neat to
find
things like this that
that show us what our history is these
these little
features in our evolutionary design if
you want to call it that
they just really demonstrate hey your
ancestors were fish
so i that's that's what got me excited
about this when i saw it
please feel free to ask some more
questions here
are the bones in our ears also to be
found in other species
yes they are um
birds and reptiles just have one we have
three bones let me get back to that
slide here
so you can't see it super well in this
diagram but we actually have three bones
and reptiles and birds only have one
this
this little round one down here actually
just connects
from the cochlea straight to the eardrum
in birds and reptiles
and most birds and reptiles some of them
have weird systems
um instead that they've evolved
but these other two bones actually came
from our jaws
so that when if you look at mammal
evolution
the early reptile-like mammals they had
a jawbone
much like reptiles do today where
there's actually
um there's several bones in the jaw
and the the jaw articulates in a very
different way on the skull
so i've done i don't have my
bird skulls here with me in canada
because i was actually borrowing them
from um
from a wildlife center when i used to do
videos on those
if you go back you can see if you go
back through my
this data casually videos you can see
when i do
uh there's a series of videos on what's
at wednesday where i show off different
skulls and i talk about their anatomy
and if you go back and look at that you
can see how how different
mammal articulation of the jaw is
compared to birds and compared to
reptiles actually didn't ever do a
reptile skull but i did bird skulls
i think i might have showed a i should
pictures of a crocodile skull i never
had one
but uh in those videos you can see
the very how weird it is that you know
these
reptiles and birds have an extra bone in
their jaw
and their lower jaw and in their upper
jaw and
mammals don't seem to have that they
seem to have lost those two bones well
those two bones actually went into the
inner ear
a lot of reptiles used their jaw to
magnify
their their hearing abilities so snakes
i'm sure you've heard about this that
they can only hear when they're they
have their
head on the ground they actually have an
inner ear they've
they've got the same sensory organs
inside that we do they've got the
they have a version of the cochlea it's
not it's not wound up like ours is but
they have a
something similar to the cochlea and
it's got the hair cells inside there
but they they use their jaw bone
their entire jaw to pick up vibrations
in the ground and they can't hear that
well
when their head is lifted up
what our ancestors did is you can
actually see this
in the evolution of mammals
their jaw starts to articulate on two
different spots
and then it switches from one to the
other and then there's this extra piece
of bone that's doing nothing
and that ends up migrating into the ear
over evolutionary time
and a bone from the top of the skull
migrates into the ear as well
and then you get this this three bone
system that really does a good job
magnifying sound so
that is something you can see in the
fossil record unfortunately i did not
prepare slides
to show that to you but let's see
the the cyanodance already had those ear
bones right i'm actually
i can't remember which actual species
um that the transition occurs in but
there are
the or what what group of animals the
transition occurs in but
there there is one species where you can
see the the jaw articulates in two
different ways
and it's it's really neat because it
shows you this huge
transition in jaw morphology where
i don't know actually how it would have
even worked in this organism they must
have had a lot of cartilage in there
and needed a loose a fairly loose jaw
maybe they were
opening their mouths so wide they needed
a really loose articulation but
there are there is a fossil species and
i am forgetting the name if anyone knows
it
uh let me know in the in the comments
here but
it is it's really neat because you can
see that the jaw articulates in two
spots
and then from there uh we get this
switch to a completely different
articulation method
in mammals that just didn't happen in
other organisms and that freed up this
bone to be used in the ear
anthony asks arthropods also come from
water did they use
their antenna for hearing and water i'm
actually not sure about that um
probably the thing about insects is that
they have
a lot of um sensory organs that stick
out of their bodies little spike like
things
and those those can sense all sorts of
vibrations
and there's a lot of different the weird
thing about
insects and and arthropods in general is
that they just have tons of different
ways to sense vibrations uh
their their
their antenna can do all sorts of things
from sensing smells to
to sounds to uh you know tasting
their food and so on and
they're yeah i'm sure there's there's
lots of different ways that
insects are hearing in the water because
there's lots of different ways that
they're hearing on land as well
see
m5 says the jaws came from the gills the
ear bones came from the jaw
and the whales use their jaws
to hear underwater evolution is a mess
yeah nothing really happens in a
straight line
so whales whales have a special
glob of fat in their jaw that helps them
also magnify sound which is really
interesting
and like i said that their ears all
their their inner ear it's
you can tell it came from a normal
mammalian inner ear because the three
bones are in there but they don't
function
the way that they do in land mammals
so anyway i think i think that answers
the question oh what do insects come
from water before our ancestors yes
insects came out on land way before the
rest of us did
us tetrapods did and i
i'm really bad with numbers so i can't
tell you exactly when that happened like
how much earlier
but yeah uh crustaceans have been living
on land
for a very very long time and uh
yeah there's crustaceans are coming out
on land
have have been evolving onto land and
back on into the sea again
ever since uh i've got a video called
the evidence of evolution at the beach
which is on this
this channel stated casually channel and
that talks about the
um the evolution of lawn shrimp
and it's it's a more recent transition
from the land
from uh to the land from the sea but
yeah crustaceans have been doing this
way longer than we have i mean tetrapods
have been going back and forth from
land to sea quite a bit too you've got
you know the first big event
uh where you get the first
uh amphibians evolving from fish
but then you get all sorts of returns
back to the sea you have
sea turtles for example i've gone back
to the sea from the land
whales sea lions or like you know
intermediate otters or intermediate you
have these semi-aquatic mammals
you have all of the uh marine reptiles
all the marine reptiles that were living
alongside the dinosaurs
there's a whole bunch of them a bunch of
different transitions back into the sea
so
evolution really is a mess it doesn't
just go one way it goes
a lineage will just follow the
opportunities that happen to be in front
of it during
its current you know time period
and opportunities where the best
opportunities are that changes over time
sometimes the water is is better than
land sometimes land is better than water
and it's just uh yeah it's
it's a mess evolution is a mess
does archaeopteryx have reptile or bird
ears
and jaw so birds birds have
ears that are very similar to crocodiles
um
and i don't think that we have the
inner ear bones of archaeopteryx i don't
think
i've never seen them before if they have
been preserved i mean archaeopteryx is
tiny and then those
those bones would have been super tiny
but
yeah i think the difference between a
bird ear
and a crocodile ear is would be
extremely hard to tell
in the fossil record so um
it and by the way birds and crocodiles
are
the animal most closely related to birds
that's alive today
it it's the crocodiles those are the
closest living relatives to birds
and they they have a very similar jaw
the articulation is in the same spot and
the uh the ears are very similar
so
anyway that was a rather short uh
oh i got one more question do whales use
their ears and echo
location or some other structure yes
they are using their ears
it's it's their hearing um
is is what they're using and
something interesting there's a there's
a protein in the ear called preston
and it's actually used not by the hair
cells that i was showing you
by a different set of hair cells that
are used to magnify
sound inside the cochlea
and the it it's this really elastic
uh structure and it attaches
i'm stepping out of my lane trying to
explain how this works it's been years
since i read about this but it attaches
two membranes together inside the
cochlea i believe
and it's it's really elastic and
it it actually responds to sound itself
and will
pull tight when it when it's stimulated
by sound
and it increases pulling on a membrane
and that increases
the the sound inside the ear and whales
have a very special preston protein
that helps helps them hear really really
high frequencies
uh well dolphins and and so on do
and that's that aids in their echo
location but yeah they're just using
their ears
yeah that happy easter everyone
this was another episode of sunday
morning science
hopefully that was uh informative i i
had a good time
uh that was kind of one of my random
uh rabbit holes i went into this week
just reading different papers and i
actually have i believe
i have in my slides i believe i included
the paper ah here it is let me show you
this is the paper on the
sensory hair cell death and regeneration
in fishes and it explains
uh how the i mean it's about it's about
cell death
and regeneration so they're trying to
study how deafness works
when uh these hair cells get messed up
in the human ear
and they're using fish as a model and
they talk about how
the the lateral line can be used or the
actual ear of the fish can be used
and in this paper they make an argument
for using the inner ear
i didn't know this until i had read this
paper but in the past
almost all of our research on hearing
was done on the
lateral line of fish because it's so
easily accessible it's really easy to
study
how these cells work on the side of a
fish
but this paper is recommending that we
look more at the actual ear of fish
especially really easy to raise in a lab
and it is harder to get access to the
ear of a fish but the cells inside there
act a little bit more similar
to the cells in the human ear so
anyway let's see
keith asks are there other fluids in our
body that are leftovers from fish
uh yeah i mean
our our blood is uh i mean
we we evolved in the ocean
uh and we actually you can actually
think of our body as kind of like a
a dry a space suit for living on land or
our skin is
or we we've got a reverse wetsuit that
we're wearing
because our our skin just holds in
moisture and it holds in what is
essentially salt water right
our cells evolved in a marine
environment
and all cells need you know
need something very similar to a marine
environment so our our blood
and the fluid in our cells is very
similar
to the salt content of the ocean it's
not exact
but this is uh this is because of our
evolutionary history so
a lot of our our body shows this
this marine ancestry that we have
uh i'm getting a happy easter from my
dad ah my dad's watching
happy easter to you uh and yet next week
i will
i will probably have mike on hopefully
that'll that will be next week
and we're going to talk about uh why it
is
that multi-celled organisms like
ourselves and
by the way mike is my identical twin
brother we're going to be talking about
why it is that multi-celled organisms
like ourselves which evolve
so slowly because it takes so long for
us to reproduce
why it is that microbes cannot evolve so
fast they can overtake us and cause our
extinction
that was the question that he had for me
you know which kind of stimulated by all
this
you know new thought process everyone
was having
with the virus and the virus evolution
kind of asking these questions
and i thought that was a really cool
question to dive into because the
answers to it are really interesting and
it's
you know we'll probably take a whole
hour talking about that so i'm excited
about that
so so long for now stay curious